you know what i look at patrick holmes
numbers right now i looked at the way
he's playing i look at his body language
i'm gonna say this patrick mahomes is
not a top five quarterback in the nfl
right now he just isn't you know the
chiefs remind me of the seahawks several
years ago except for the chiefs its
offense for the seahawks it was defense
they made it to one super bowl and they
won they made it to another one and
looked horrible that's where the chiefs
are right now people are figuring them
out defensive coordinators aren't stupid
and i think that's the biggest thing
that patrick mahomes is gonna have to
deal with the magic they're taking away
so many of those plays if you can shut
down tyreek hill if you can get him away
from some of those fluke things he did
the first three first couple seasons in
the nfl six turnovers in the last uh
three games he has six interceptions
this year that's how many he had all of
last year um just 2.67 touchdowns
for each interception 95 better
quarterbacks in the nfl thank you for
asking me here here's my justification
that patrick mahomes is no longer a top
five quarterback in the nfl hopefully he
can turn that around but here's here's
how i look at it right now justin
herbert
what can you say the guy is he's dan
marino meets joe montana meets troy
aikman
where are you this weekend
it doesn't matter doesn't matter where
were you hey speaking of that what about
bill belichick going against rookie
quarterbacks uh-huh
that guy made him look uh or he didn't
have as much luck with the houston
quarterback but anyway i got herbert
number one because for the next 10 15
years he's just gonna be amazing tom
brady number two kyler murray you know
until they figure him out or figure out
a way to stop him i got him in the top
five josh allen how do you argue with
that aaron rodgers is still there i'm
going to go with joe burrell lamar
jackson and then patrick mahomes at
number eight and he's tied with matthew
stafford
he's tied for number eight right now
lamar jackson yes
and aaron rodgers who we both buried
three weeks ago no we buried him four
weeks ago that was just after one week
and that was just temporary we only hit
him hard for one week but that's what
i'm saying that's what this is right my
homes like
those interceptions last night
one was a tip one was a should have been
caught so it's the numbers can you know
they they can fool you a little bit i
think
i think what he needs to assess is the
fact that he
the type of guy he is just the law of
percentages
all those bs like falling down behind
the back under the leg throws that have
been caught for touchdowns like
those are going to stop falling they're
a little loose they're playing a little
loose for sure and what's going to see
if he's going to be
the type of quarterback to fulfill sort
of this
you know mount rushmore that they've put
him on already is if he can adjust if he
can do the brady thing where like that's
what makes brady so great i think is
he's going to be whatever quarterback is
needed in the system to win for that
team
so i think we all play to the back of
our card eventually man i think
everybody plays to the back of their
cards you mean their career stats and
they are who they are
here
i equate mahomes in that kansas city
offense it's sort of like a run and gun
offense in the nba in basketball that
maybe they the defenses find a way to
slow you down and now you got to become
a half court offense i don't know if
they're wired that way when you make
that magic happen with the behind the
back flips and throw it up for grabs and
tyreke hill's going to run they're
missing kareem hunt they're missing
they're missing that that guy can still
play by the way kareem hunt you know he
could still definitely play yeah and you
know the kid that they have from lsu you
know he's always hurt you know he's got
talent but he's always hurt so i don't
know i think this is a this is a moving
target a flush list that can change week
by week but you look at the body
language even andy reed doesn't kind of
carry that same kind of vibe on the side
like it looks a little more confused
right chomping on that gum and
but i still i still think they feel like
one of those teams that
comes in way too hot way too cocky they
kind of get humbled a little bit and
then when they figure it out you won't
play them in the playoffs no no that's
what i'm saying kansas city no i would
not be afraid to play i think buffalo
beats them almost any time they play him
anyway you don't think so nope buffler's
got them figured out
way more physical it is the nfl like you
know how hard it is to beat a team
multiple times so i think
it's almost i remember early in brady's
career those belichick games sometimes
where they would lose early on in the
season and it almost felt like they lost
on purpose yeah they kept tricks in
their pocket they were like we know
we're gonna face these guys in the
playoffs yep it's better to
have lost to the team the first i
remember the cowboys would be way better
but i i see that way way better but you
know what i don't see the chiefs doing
that they they didn't give me that vibe
the last few weeks that they're holding
something back they're playing bad i
can't remember in college we had a team
that we would smoke every year in the uh
we would smoke them every year in in the
regular season and it almost got
annoying playing them in the conference
tournament and then we actually beat
them in the conference tournament and
they got an at-large bid to our region
and we had beaten these guys five times
already this year and it was just like
man we got to play these guys again and
for them it was the every game against
us was the freaking world series every
game against us they just wanted to
knock off the big dog and frost was like
how many times did we got how many like
stop already like it was annoying and
when they beat us the last time they
beat us was in the in the regional
championship to go to the world series
the one time they beat us was there and
i can see that being again i just think
when you've gone to the super bowl two
years in a row you know week five just
it's hard to get fired out i disagree i
disagree what was the final score what
was the final score last night again
they hammered them it was 38 to 20 or
something i mean it was so
but
what was it it was what 4-0 the josh
allen arnold had to throw 26.
the fact that it was still
two what two pick six two pick six one i
don't wanna pick six two picks a fumble
like
when you clean that stuff up like
obviously you can't have you can't beat
any team nfl when you have four
turnovers like that yeah but that's
easier said than done because i think
defenses know how to play them a little
bit differently the whole thing with the
chiefs is confidence and they're lacking
that
if they don't have it he's going to be
reserved on his throws he's going to be
trying to force him
you know who mahomes is right now he's
cody bellinger
he comes in hot just a crazy talent the
league's made an adjustment against him
but but it's like the league's made the
adjustment what are you gonna do this is
like this year is gonna
kind of set the trajectory for the rest
of his career right where it's like
the defenses started playing him
differently he became the guy can he
overcome it well this is almost to both
of your points brett favre has said this
in his in his post career he said i just
didn't give a about the regular
season oh he was like i would throw i
would throw the ball if they intercepted
it intercepted it i knew that i was
gonna make more plays than i didn't i
was going for the highlights i was going
to put up 400 yards and four touchdowns
that's what i was going he said he
didn't really he didn't watch film like
and then he was like then he then he
would try to turn it on in the playoffs
and he never got it done again though he
went to four nfc championships and never
got it done again i don't think there's
any comparison with that now i i think
he's a gunsh slinger like farve but i
guarantee you patrick holmes is watching
film he's taking this serious i don't
think you take that i think they're
figuring it out i think he's lost a
little bit of confidence i just see
their star falling a little bit and what
they're two games out of first place in
their own division he might be the
second best quarterback in 17 games this
year no i know there is but there's a
very good chance they're not gonna play
every playoff game at home i mean you
want to go to buffalo no this is the
middle of january that'll be that'll be
the real test yeah but i think i just
think this is this is it like you said
he hasn't looked mahomes asked but
i'm gonna this is that this is happening
in the playoffs one time in 30 years
before we're worried about the bills in
the playoffs but you were singing the
praises of the bills last year i love
the bills but i'm not picking them to
win the super bowl until yeah but no but
look if you watch a team and are they
making that next step and i think you
could say that about the bills as long
as josh allen doesn't have to throw 40
times a game if you have him throw 26
times a game you don't have to worry
about his accuracy if they gave out the
lombardi in october the dallas cowboys
would have 30 of these things are you
kidding me don't worry about this man
hey by the way before we move on to the
next segment i'm going to say it again
right here
number eight tied with matthew stafford
right now behind justin herbert tom
brady kyler murray josh allen aaron
rodgers joe burrow lamar jackson and
then he comes in at number eight are you
going by fantasy ring no i don't even
play fantasy so you're telling me gun to
your head all right you lose and you die
you pick joe burrow over patrick mahomes
for your life on the line
what what is this the evolution of
hunger games this is squid games all
right squid games i'm that guy running
right now yeah
yep harvey dent has your child and you
have you need to win a game to save your
child and your your bet is on joe burrow
instead of pat mahomes yeah joe burrow
right now he's number eight on my list
tied with matthew stafford very sorry
dasher that's going to grow up
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]